Nayomi graduations on your book it's
already garnered
lots of attention there's a section of
the Guardian website devoted to it
Harper's has excerpted it and it's in
the Amazon stratosphere and if I want to
go out on a limb and say it's going to
get a lot more attention and I think
that's because there's been a lot of
tumult over the course of the last
couple years and in the wake of Iraq in
the wake of Hurricane Katrina I think
that there is an appetite for some sort
of unified theory to explain what's
happened and you provide one and it's
called disaster capitalism could you
unpack disaster capitalism yeah the
phrase disaster capitalism I think
sometimes people think I'm talking just
about a few contractors making a quick
buck in Iraq or or New Orleans and and I
am talking about that but I'm talking
about a lot more than that disaster
capitalism is is the harnessing of a
large-scale disaster it could be a
natural disaster like Katrina or the
Asian tsunami it could be a war could be
a terrorist attack could be an economic
crisis these disasters aren't created
obviously in some in some evil plot the
in order to exploit but what I'm arguing
is that these disasters are being
harnessed by right-wing ideologues to
push through policies that they couldn't
push through under normal circumstances
so Katrina is a case in point where
after the levees broke the city flooded
people were dispersed throughout the
country I'm not arguing that this is
some vast conspiracy or plot but I am
arguing that this was recognized by
ideologues in Washington as an
opportunity to turn New Orleans into a
laboratory for free-market economics a
that there's something almost inherent
in the ideology of this far right-wing
economics that demands these kinds of
crises right yeah well what I'm arguing
is that the central claim of the of the
free-market crusade and you know I want
to be clear that I'm talking I'm not
talking about all kinds of market
economics or all kinds of capitalism I'm
talking about the very radical strain
of what sometimes referred to as Chicago
school economics the Milton Friedman
view of the world which holds that the
only acceptable role for government is
really to enforce contracts and to
police borders and everything else
should be left to the market so this is
a very radical vision and yeah I'm
arguing that it actually is impossible
to push through that radical vision in
the absence of a crisis you can do it
piecemeal in the absence of a crisis but
to go whole hog in what economists often
refer to as economic shock therapy which
is sort of a tsunami of policy and a
privatization deregulation cuts to
government spending that that the only
moments when it's been possible to push
through the whole package and lead sort
of leaps forward the kind of big bang
moments for the advancement of this
ideology there has had to have been some
kind of a crisis once again the argument
is not that the crisis was created so
that it could be exploited but that the
crisis was recognized as an opportunity
so I I was a little bit confused on this
point in your book to be honest because
you draw a very extended metaphor
between actual physical torture and
economic shock therapy and you know the
torturer has a desire doesn't care if he
inflicts long-term damage on his subject
and are you implying that somebody like
Jeffrey Sachs or Paul Wolfowitz intended
to inflict that kind of long-term damage
on the objects of their either the
parallel first of all I got interested
in the issue of shock because this was
the metaphor and I didn't pull this
metaphor out of thin air I I became
interested in the metaphor because it
was the metaphor of choice being used by
the economist referring to their
policies as economic shock treatment
economic shock therapy the war in Iraq
was called shock and awe and I when I
when I returned from Iraq actually in
2004 having reported on the intersection
between economic shock therapy and shock
and awe and and torture mmm real shocks
to bodies I I wanted to understand how
shock actually worked on the human mind
and so I started reading
interrogation manuals declassified CIA
interrogation manuals mm-hmm and what
they describe there's one in particular
the 1963 kubark manual which was
Declassified in the late 90s and it was
based on the research that was done
under MKULTRA and the manual starts by
saying every technique we're about to
we're about to describe is essentially a
method for inducing regression and then
it goes on to talk about how
disorientation and cutting the prisoner
off from their ability to communicate
with their senses sight sound touch
disorientation between day and night how
this is heightened and a window of
opportunity opens up and that window of
opportunity is the state of shock it's a
it's a manual for how to to induce that
state of shock and shock is really a
synonym in this manual for a state of
regression the conversion of adults into
a childlike state and then it says a
window opens up and in that window the
prisoner is less likely it is less able
to protect their interests and they
start to see their interrogator as a
father figure so the parallel that I'm
drawing is that that idea of the open
the window that opens up in a state of
shock which is actually based on all
these psychological experiments there
the parallel is that in its in a whole
society that gets hit by a major shock
as something similar happens especially
if the shock is heightened by political
leaders who you know who heightened that
the dislocation the disorientation and
people start seeing their politicians as
father figures like thinking Rudy
Giuliani is their long-lost daddy and
read this and you know a shock like if
we think of September 11th shock like
that is really about a gap opening up
between event and analysis about that
event that's what a shock is something
so big happens that you can't process it
it's an event without a story right so
what people naturally want to do in that
moment is find a story they want they
want to somehow get there their
narrative back so after September 11
people wanted to read history they want
an analysis they wanted to talk to their
neighbors they wanted to connect the
Bush administration says go shopping and
knowledge of history or context is
justifying these acts of terror so what
I'm arguing is that the impulse to take
advantage of the window of opportunity
that opens up in a state of shock and I
think that this has been happening after
these cataclysmic events I think the
Bush administration did it after
September 11th I think they did it after
Katrina I think they did it in Iraq
after the shock and awe invasion under
Paul Bremer is it is working on the same
psychological premise of the window of
opportunity when you when when a society
regresses and you know I'll quote
Richard Armitage when he was describing
the strategy in Iraq he said the working
premise was that after shock and awe and
the collapse of Saddam Iraqis would be
easy to Marshall from point A to point B
and he turned out to be wrong but that
was the theory I just wanted to I mean
since we're on the subject of Iraq which
is really one of the centerpieces of
your book and really to me it was one of
you know you shoehorned Iraq into a
theory that I wasn't I wasn't entirely
expecting it's go you know I hear a lot
of times that the war in Iraq was fought
over oil and Alan Greenspan
confirmed that recently in an interview
that he was discussing but he was
talking about fighting the war for oil
for for very different reasons than you
describe him he seemed to be talking
about doing it in order to to protect to
protect the region against the threat
that he considered Saddam Hussein to
represent he used the phrase oil
security and I think oil security really
just means steady access to oil because
it's the Bush administration uses it in
relation to Canada as well and the
Alberta tar says let me just read a just
a passage from from your book you say
it's hard to believe but then again that
was pretty much Washington's gameplan
for Iraq shocked and terrorized the
entire country deliberately ruined its
infrastructure do nothing while its
culture and history are ransacked to
make it all okay with an unlimited
supply of cheap household appliances and
imported junk food in Iraq the cycle of
culture erasing and culture replacing
was not theoretical it was all unfolded
in a matter of weeks so if I'm reading
you right it sounds like you're saying
that decay
that resulted at the outbreak of the
warren continues to the present was
something that was calculated well you
know what I'm arguing in the book is
that there is an extreme not that it's
calculated but there is an extreme
comfort level with disaster widget which
isn't to say that Donald Rumsfeld wanted
Iraq to be looted mmm but he did shrug
and say stuff happens when he found out
that it was and that's what I mean that
that that that it's um that there's an
understanding that when when this kind
of chaos takes place it actually is an
opportunity and there's the in imperial
life in the Emerald City Rajeev Chandra
Chandra said Karen talks about how all
of these CPA officials reacted to the
looting right like the the person who
was in charge of Iraq's universities
looked at the universities being looted
and thought well that'll help me because
I need to replace this entire education
system anyway so they're sort of just
you know doing the demolition stage for
me and I really do think that that was
you know someone like Thomas Friedman
described the mission in Iraq not as
nation building but nation creating
create a model for well I think that
that this was quite open but I just want
to contextualize the quote that you just
just read right because it was it was um
you know I was drawing I was drawing an
analogy between what was happening what
has happened in Guantanamo where
prisoners are held for four years and
then I was very shocked to learn in some
of the testimony that's come out of
Guantanamo that there is this odd
building and which is known by the
prisoners and the guards is the Love
Shack and when a prisoner is to be
returned home they're taken to the Love
Shack for a few days and given Pringles
and fast food and allowed to watch
Hollywood movies and then sent home so I
quote one of the prisoners one of the
Tipton's three the British prisoners who
says you know I think that they were
trying to make up for the fact that they
tortured us for three years right by
giving us Pringles and fast food so yeah
I said well I guess you know it sounds
crazy but look at what what they did in
Iraq the country was looted nobody tried
to stop it it was bombed and then it was
all supposed to be okay because Paul
Bremer rides in and says Iraq is open
for business
you know the shop so from the shopping
respect the perspective of disaster
capitalism was the Iraq war a success I
think no and yes in the sense that there
was a plan a and the plan a we could we
we can see what that plan a was just
because Paul Bremer left you know a
copious paper trail and Germer was
already like Plan B or C right I mean
he'd already come in on the wing after
it in the wake of the failure of Jay
garner and the initial plan which was to
be greeted as that with you know flowers
and candy well I think that Garner was I
think that Bremer wasn't actually Plan B
I think I think that it was actually
Bremer was brought in at that stage
because because Rumsfeld felt vindicated
actually by how quickly Baghdad fell and
garner had always been pushed on him by
the State Department and he was riding
the the success of the invasion the fact
that he had predicted it would be a
cakewalk that it kinda was and then they
got their guy in Paul Bremer on this
country creation mission and if we look
at what Paul Bremer did that first
summer there was quite the swagger to
his step running around Iraq with his
Blackwater security guards and just you
know announcing one of the first things
he announced was that Iraq was open for
business
absolutely unrestricted free trade he
unveiled a new foreign investment law
that was described by The Economist as
the wish list for foreign investors
which meant that the foreign companies
could come in on a hundred percent of
Iraqi assets and take a hundred percent
of the profits out in all of this there
was you know 40 or 50 of these edicts
that's what I mean by the paper trail it
was even the 15 percent flat tax which
is a Republican sort of a pet policy
that's never been imposed exactly you
couldn't you couldn't get it in
Washington so let's get it in Baghdad so
I think plan a we just have to look at
what Bremer did plan a was to turn a
rock into a model free market and then
to introduce democracy and I think it's
important to get the order right because
it was very it was it was crucial for an
in Bremer's period that he do this
extreme country makeover before Iraqis
were allowed to vote and the his real
political battle while he was there was
that Iraqis kept trying to vote before
he was finished right and so there were
local elections that were cancelled by
Bremer and then there were huge demands
in that first year big protests in
Baghdad in Basra demanding immediate
elections to appoint the first
government the first government and and
and and and this was overridden by Bush
and Bremer who said no we're going to
appoint that government so and I really
do think it's important to understand
the order because you know we often hear
that the goal was to bring Iraqis
democracy but it was a very particular
kind of democracy in which all the
decisions will be made first and then
they would be allowed to vote what's
your diagnosis then of why I mean even
you know the if let's say III you know
looking back over the the narratives the
war it seems to me that you know garner
was sent in because they didn't really
care to plan there was this view that it
would you know it's order everything
would happen organically in the wake of
the invasion and Bremer comes in and
Bremer is making up a lot of these
decisions relatively on on the fly he's
clearly falling back on ideological
predilections and he's got a lot of kind
of hacked Republicans around him who
have these free market ideas that
they're taking off the shelf in opposing
but why then wasn't the whole occupation
planned for in advance if this was
intended to create this free-market
society that you described I mean it
seems like well first of all no I I
don't actually think it was that
deliberate I don't think Iraq was
invaded so that it could be turned into
a free market economy I think Iraq was
invaded
you know I the explanation that rings
true is to me is is in Ron Suskind
one-percent doctrine it's it's it's the
Cheney idea of needing to send a message
to the world that this is what happens
when you mess with the United States and
that that that Afghanistan did not
present a target-rich enough environment
for that kind of form of mass violent
communication and Iraq was chosen to
and that message to the world for a
variety of reasons one because it was a
target-rich environment two because as
Alan Greenspan said it's was sitting on
the third-largest oil reserves in the
world three because there was practice
in the sense of the first the first Gulf
War was had been rethought in wargames
by the US military for 12 years and in
fact the shock-and-awe manual which was
the sort of guidebook for the invasion
was not a generalized war strategy if
you read the shock-and-awe manual it
starts by saying this manual is
answering the question if we had the
Gulf War to fight over again how would
we do it and make Saddam's army fall
well right so it was always a guidebook
for refighting that war and so I think
that so all of these forces converged
and when once it was clear that Iraq was
going to be invaded then and there was
obviously as we all know there was a
battle between the State Department and
the Pentagon and Rumsfeld won the first
round he won because because the war was
what was over quickly and garner was was
the less ambitious plan you know Garner
was okay let's have quick and dirty
elections let's secure the oil and let
the IMF finish the job I mean it wasn't
a plan for ongoing occupation and it was
because I think Rumsfeld was so
vindicated or seemed to be for a little
while there in his in his downsized
military shock-and-awe strategy that
that he was able to do something much
more ambitious than was planned which
was to follow the Tom Friedman vision of
let's do some country creation which is
reading reading reading your your your
book it seems like there was a measure
of intention you're arguing there was a
measure of intentionality - for some
people - the failure just because it
requires them to fall back on
privatizing reconstruction privatizing
warfare it sounds like you're arguing
that this great debate that happened
before the war about the for size where
you had Shinseki and a lot of other
people saying is you're crazy to go in
with such a small number of troops
occupying a country requires this vast
army but Rumsfeld and his ilk argued no
we need to go in with this
small footprint because it's the future
of warfare
and and in you seem to be implying that
Rumsfeld in his oak were making this
argument because they wanted to
basically privatize in the end the
revolution that they wanted was the
privatization of all these various forms
of warfare
well what I'm arguing is that there were
two private simultaneous privatized
actually there were three simultaneous
automatisation agendas going on swirling
around the Iraq war there was the one
that we could see from Bremer which was
very open about you know riding in and
announcing the privatization of the
state companies there was the
longer-term plans to privatize Iraq's
oil and and the hope that this would
spread to surrounding countries because
Saudi Arabia Kuwait Iran these are all
highly protected economies and in fact
this is a one part of the world besides
North Korea that really exists outside
of the so-called Washington Consensus I
mean these are highly even US allies in
the region like Saudi Arabia ninety
percent of that economy is controlled by
the monarchy this is not a free market
economy so there were all kinds of is
all kinds of there were ideas that this
there would be a tsunami of oil
privatization and papers written by the
American Enterprise Institute at the
time explaining this so but the third
level of privatization was inside the
military itself and this was a huge part
of Rumsfeld's transformation vision and
on September the 10th 2001 on that
fateful day Donald Rumsfeld unveiled
this plan in a town hall meeting at the
Pentagon extraordinarily controversial
speech that he made where he declared
war on the Pentagon bureaucracy and
unveiled a vision for a sort of hollow
military and it was basically when he
went in there like a sort of new economy
CEO that was saying you know we're not
going to produce products anymore we're
going to produce brands and we're going
to outsource everything and this is what
he was saying to the Pentagon
bureaucracy was saying why are we
sorting our own mail why do we have
doctors treating soldiers when this can
be done by private companies and he had
a huge list of things that were being
done in-house that he believed could be
done by private companies and let's
remember that he spent two and a half
decades in the private sector I argue
that he was very much a card-carrying
member of what I'm calling the disaster
capitalism
complex he was chair of the board
affiliate sciences which is a company
that produces AIDS drugs and Tamiflu
which is the treatment of choice for
avian flu which is you know in other
words it's a company that actually
profits from the threat of disaster and
pandemic and you know he had a vision he
had this vision of the hollow state rums
chain Cheney you know was somebody else
who in his role in the private sector
was at the forefront of this radical
vision of the hollow state he was doing
that at Halliburton the hollowing out of
the sort of the the military campaign in
the Balkans you had the first stage of
what we've seen in Iraq with the fully
privatized bases kind of run as
Halliburton city-states so you know I so
so what what I'm arguing in the book is
that plan a was in fact to turn Iraq
into a model for a market economy that
was that was the real wish but the
project was rigged so that it couldn't
fail which is to say that when plan a
turned out to be a drastic
miscalculation and Iraqis rejected this
and and and the are and the insurgency
began that because the privatization
ethos had had entered the heart of the
invasion itself under Rumsfeld where you
where you had this you you had a very
downsized army surrounded by contractors
and as things got worse in Iraq and
Rumsfeld refused to send more troops
that meant that contractors filled the
gap and you had this very dramatic
mission creep that we're continuing to
see now this is part of what I'm arguing
is the shocked is the Shock Doctrine
because that crisis created a context
where there wasn't a debate about
whether you know in private private
contractors should be involved in
interrogation or whether you know in
fact nobody has any clue about the
extent of really the private operation
that exists alongside the Army in Iraq
at this point right well in fact we get
glimpses of it only through scandal this
is what's really quite remarkable is
that this agenda that that you know was
pushed through after September 11th and
then in the crisis as the war in Iraq
you know went off the rails we you know
if you read the New York Times The
Washington Post and the reports on
what's going on with black
water in Iraq you hear well there's
between 20,000 and 48,000 private
security firms private security soldiers
in Iraq well how many I mean why is
there such a gap between you know there
could be even more we don't have any
accurate count so what we're finding out
is you know this was never debated they
were never there were never there was
never a public discussion about
something as crucial
you know security that the the fact that
is the government's job to provide
security you know that that's that's
that's a constitutional mandate so there
was never this debate and we find out
about this corporate mission creep
scandal by scandal so during the Abu
Ghraib scandal we find out that it
wasn't just soldiers who were involved
there were private contractors who are
involved in the interrogation and when
there's a shootout in Baghdad and the
Iraqi government says they want to ban
Blackwater we find out you know the
extent of Blackwater's involved the
reason that we rely so heavily on
contractors in Iraq it's not no I can I
can see that it looks dodgy that you
have these conflicts of interest where
you have somebody like Cheney coming out
of Halliburton you have Halliburton
profiting off of the war but it seems to
me that that more than the profit motive
I don't think that's terribly
significant it seems to me that this is
a lot of times sleight of hand that
you're not there's been a reluctance to
sell to tell to be straight with the
American public about the cost of war
and so you don't want to have a high
troop level because it makes the war see
more burdensome than it actually is and
that the reliance on contractors there's
some ideological component to it but
there's also a public relations
component to it um I think there's also
an ideological component to it and I
think if we look at who the key figures
of this administration are and also the
key figures who you know who who
demanded this war most loudly they are
embedded in this economy of disaster and
and Dick Cheney and his wife on the
board of Lockheed Martin air Lockheed
Martin has in the 90s was you know
major engine of this vision of a hollow
government you know when Clinton slashed
military spending and Lockheed and other
weapons companies started to see that
there that they needed to diversify
because their main area was shrinking
their you know their main market was
shrinking the where Lockheed started to
diversify was saying to the government
okay we already have security clearance
so we there's all kinds of functions
that you're performing that we could do
so Lockheed starts you know sorting the
mail cutting welfare checks performing
core government functions and this
hollowing out of the government was
really being pushed by that company
Halliburton was doing the same thing on
the military and so I'm saying it's both
ideological and its financial I mean
this seems clear so you're saying for
those personal people yeah yeah Dick
Cheney with his massive Halliburton
holdings do you think he's doing it for
charity
I mean I know that we think such
wonderful things about I don't think but
I also think that that maybe he drank
the kool-aid when it was also really
profitable I mean things are
simultaneous because you have an
ideology hmm
that that that that conveniently is a
justification for greed I mean the
ideology is pursue your greed feed
economic growth and everything will be
fixed in the trickle-down like I don't I
can't separate the ideology friend I
also see a lot of other people who were
prime architects of the war who didn't
have this ideological this financial
incentive somebody like Wolfowitz or
Bill Kristol or George W Bush
I don't think especially right had it
was very close family Holdings to
Carlyle which is a major weapons company
and he's very close to the oil industry
and lady Stark is actually benefited
from this war it's the military
companies
it's the contractors who are doing the
heavy reconstruction and it's the oil
industry which didn't get their oil boom
in Iraq but they got it in every other
part of the world it seems like because
the price of oil has grown up to $75 but
it's been it's been a flop for these
guys on a lot of levels I mean they're
the reputations are ruined it's you know
somebody like Rumsfeld it's hard to know
what he's going to do when he's
during a think tank about the connection
between security and free-market
economics is QED okay and but but and
just for the economy in general it's not
been exactly but I really do think that
when we say this has been a failure this
has been a disaster we need to ask for
who because for Halliburton for Lockheed
for Gilead Sciences for the key you know
for Beck tell you another figure who was
really very prominent you're talking
about immaturity you're talking about a
very narrow sector of the whole economy
but one in which I'm talking about the
people who really created the case for
this war I mean the the committee for
the liberation of Iraq was created by a
former vice president of Lockheed Martin
who didn't have to sell as chairs George
Shultz was the chair of that committee
and he was on the board of Bechtel the
whole time so yeah I realize it seems
simplistic and obvious but I believe
that I'm gonna have to cut you off
because we're gonna have to take a quick
break but we will after the break resume
this discussion wonderful afterwards and
several others c-span programs are
available for download as podcasts more
with Naomi Klein and Franklin for in a
moment next Sunday on book TV Lynne
Cheney wife of Vice President Dick
Cheney and senior fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute in her latest book
blue skies no fences she recalls growing
up in Casper Wyoming mrs. Cheney is
interviewed by Nancy Gibbs
editor-at-large for Time magazine and
co-author of the recently published
Billy Graham biography the preacher and
the president's Lynne Cheney on
afterwards
next Sunday 6 p.m. Eastern only on book
TV
afterwards with Naomi Klein and Franklin
for continues just to finish up this
discussion about Iraq because your book
is about many other subjects than just
the war in Iraq since it's been a
failure on some levels you know maybe
not all levels for disaster capitalism
what are the implications of the parts
of the war that have been a failure for
for for this theory well I mean I do
think that that it has been chastening
in terms of the the that cracking open
that part of the world so I think that
that's one of the implications but but I
think it's been really frightening to I
mean this is why I'm coming back to the
issue of profit and the emergence and
and the growth of of what I'm calling
the disaster capitalism complex and this
is what Eisenhower warned against right
I mean this is not some kooky theory
when he says when he warned against the
military industrial complex what he was
saying was what was when you have such
when you have such large profits being
made from war and instability then you
have a very powerful political lobby
that has the potential to distort policy
because they have an active economic
interest in continued instability and I
think that what we're seeing and what's
what's what's quite worrying is I talk
in the book about the Davos dilemma and
this was discussed at this year's a
world economic summit in Davos every
year there's sort of a buzzword and this
in this past year was the Davos dilemma
and what was the Davos dilemma well
according to Martin wolf a columnist in
financial times and described the Davos
dilemma as the paradox that the world
was becoming more unstable more crisis
prone basically going to hell in a
handbasket hyoil prices war in Iraq
potential potential of a nuclear strike
on Iran climate change Middle East
crisis and so on and so on but at the
same time the stock market was doing
very very well and there were record
levels of economic growth so this was
the Davos dilemma
what is this paradox between the the
between political between political
crisis and isn't it interesting that in
this kind of heart of the global
economic elite in Davos they would they
would they would identify this dilemma
and find it somewhat troubling I mean it
there's you know not the section of the
elite that actually profits from
disaster capitalism is only only a swath
of the elite in a lot of other parts of
the elite find this to be to be to be
troubling and against their their
interests I think that's absolutely true
but it is an extraordinarily politically
connected part of that elite and I think
you know you see that very clearly in in
Washington and the homeland security
complex this is a really a sector of the
economy that wasn't even identified as a
sector before September 11 is now worth
200 billion dollars and that that
economy is utterly embedded in
Washington lobbying and funding for
political parties because it's not a
normal economy it's not in the free
market it's entirely dependent on
getting government contracts so it
trades entirely in political influence
this is why you know the biggest problem
at the Department of Homeland Security
is that they can't hold on to staff you
know the top level that's been evolving
so quickly and where people leave and
they go into the homeland security
complex and apply for the contracts that
they used to issue so you know I think I
really I'm arguing in the book that the
shock of September 11th the dislocation
of September 11th created the context
for a new economy that was never that
never admitted itself as such yeah I and
that and that it called itself the war
on terror right but the best way to
actually understand what the war on
terror is is as a new economy with the
Bush administration playing the role of
venture capitalists of deep pocketed
venture capitalists that you know the
way in which the war on terror has been
defined is no war against evil
everywhere forever against an enemy that
you
can't talk to because all they want is
your annihilation so that you have to
protect the homeland against any
conceivable threat and respond to any
possible threat abroad as if it's a
hundred percent threat so this is from a
military perspective unwinnable but from
an economic perspective unbeatable
because you have absolute security in
that market because that war yes let's
continue to unpack your description of
what's happened after September 11th and
kind of stay away from Iraq because
you're describing other things that have
happened we've already spent the first
half of the show discussing your back
you say September 11th appeared to
provided Washington with the green light
to stop asking countries if they wanted
to have the US version a free trade and
democracy and to start imposing it with
shock and awe military force I mean what
other than Iraq and and Afghanistan are
there other things that you're you're
thinking about when you wrote that well
I was referring specifically to Iraq but
but in the book you know I first used
the phrase disaster capitalism after the
Asian tsunami
um when and I went that I went to Sri
Lanka six months after the tsunami had
to research the reconstruction and
actually to contrast it with Iraq and I
found some really disturbing parallels
which was which is that just I'm just to
give you one example four days after the
tsunami hit the government pushed
through a water privatization law which
is quite extraordinary means Sri Lanka
first of all before the tsunami had had
elections and the party that was
proposing these neoliberal reforms
prescribed by the IMF in the World Bank
water privatization electricity
privatization labor market flexibility
all of these code words or they don't
say privatization anymore they say
public-private partnerships this
government was voted out of office and
replaced with the center-left coalition
that was promising not to do these
things so four days after the tsunami
hit hundreds of thousands of people are
displaced 40,000 people have been killed
the dead aren't even buried yet and the
government is pushing through a water
privatization bill so that's happening
in the capital that's happening in
Colombo the rest of the agenda is also
being pushed through with with renewed
fervor you know and I interviewed the
top officials at the World Bank the
Asian Development Bank had a US aid in
Sri Lanka and and on the coast that the
people who were hurt the most by the
tsunami were the coastal fishing people
these are the people who build their
homes on on the beach and and and and
and have their boats on the beach what
was happening there was that hundreds of
thousands of people around 400,000
people were moved to these inland camps
and they were told that they were being
kept there for their safety because they
were because if another tsunami came
they would be hurt meanwhile the coasts
were being handed over to large resort
developers and industrial fishing fleets
so that's also that that's the example
of what I'm talking about you know stop
asking start imposing it's the window of
opportunity that opens up and it's real
ANCA is a great example because it
actually wasn't possible to impose these
policies in the absence of a crisis they
tried and in a normal non apocalyptic
reality the party that was promising to
do it was voted out of office
does this make this libertarian ideology
that you describe any different from any
other ideology you know as you point out
in the book the New Deal emerged out of
the crisis of the Great Depression
communism the Communist revolution and
in Russia emerged out of the crisis of
World War one this just seems to me part
of the dynamic of almost every ideology
well I think that there's a qualitative
difference between the deliberate taking
advantage of the disorientation in
crisis and that people can't participate
in these decisions and using a crisis to
push forward a populist agenda that
actually has a majority of support I
would argue that the New Deal falls into
that category that it wasn't you know
that it wasn't the dislocation that was
being taken advantage of it was that
people were angry they wanted solutions
and you had a Keynesian and a and a you
know in a social democratic leadership
that was confident enough to take
advantage of that moment but I mean I'm
I'm a big fan of the New Deal myself but
you also have to argue that they
overreached and did things like try to
pack the courts and the National
Recovery Act which which promoted a
brand of regulation that I think most
Americans at the time didn't
didn't consider to be acceptable I mean
they did I mean it's they did take
advantage of the moment and they did
overreach and it's pretty well
documented well but but I still think
that there was a difference in that
moment I think there was a there was a
base support behind that behind the
initial push and and I think that where
the parallels deserve to be made is you
know looking at the bolsheviks and and
and you know the the sort of desire for
crisis and recognizing a crisis in
capital as the opportunity to push
through an agenda because I mean I think
the real difference with the New Deal is
that that was a vision for a mixed
economy you know mixed and mix-and-match
economy that was not fundamentalist I
think you know Keynesian czar
compromisers by their very nature where
where you see the parallels is with with
other fundamentalist I mean I think you
know what I'm talking about the Milton
Friedman's of the world I'm talking
about market fundamentalists who believe
in a vision of society that looks
wonderful in their mathematical models
in the basement of the University of
Chicago but our but but our one of these
systems that actually need a monopoly on
power in order to be realized because
it's all about balance right and any
distortion it you know is it is
polluting the possibility of this
balanced this promise of the perfectly
balanced market that's true for
religious fundamentalists it's true for
Marxist fanatics it's the it can't
countenance any any any other ideology
that would that sets it sets off the
balance so the it's those ideologies I
think that are very dangerous in the
moment of crisis because they imagine
the dislocation as a kind of a clean
sheet a blank slate and a moment to
build the ideal world and I think the
difference is that though the other many
of the other ideologies that have done
this you know whether it's the Taliban
you know or the Bolsheviks have actually
been held accountable for the crimes
that that have been required to build
their model states and you know what I'm
trying to do with the book is say you
know what Harold Pinter said when he won
the Nobel Prize in 2005 he said you know
the Cold War had two sides and we have
actually gone through a collect
process of reckoning with this with the
crimes of one side but we haven't with
the other side so so that's why you know
I the book we have talked about you know
Iraq and the tsunami and and New Orleans
but the book you know about three
quarters of the book is a book of modern
history from the first laboratory for
these chicago school ideas which was
Chile under Pinochet with the Chicago
boys and going through Russia Tiananmen
Square and I'm telling this history but
with the shocks and the crises left in
you know Alan Greenspan just published a
book where he looks at many of the same
chapters that talks and the Asian
financial crisis and China but he leaves
the shocks out he leaves the crises out
that were so that were so integral to
the advancement of this free-market
crusade so all I'm trying to do with the
book is put them back in so that this
ideology is actually held accountable
for its crimes in the same way that
other ideologies are um I yield to no
one in my my dislike for a lot of the
chicago school economics but you know
one of the things that be helpful to
have you kind of sort through is they're
just looking broadly at the sweep of the
chicago the chicago school and its
influence on a lot of these events when
milton friedman wasn't somebody who was
out to make a profit he was a guy who
had an idea where does this intersection
between ideas and the profit motive
happen and you know when are you able to
and how do you disentangle it i mean and
i think that this is actually an
important question and we can we can we
should we should look at it not just in
the theoretical but also kind of look at
it through the context of a lot of the
specific examples in the book yeah well
it's very hard to unpack and as i said
earlier because of this problem that the
ideology itself is a rationale for
unfettered greed but i you know i think
that for the for many of the chicago
school ideologues it was this love of
the perfect system which is always
enormous least I have to tell you can
jeans I mean as
it pains me to say it but you look at
you look at the way that a lot of the
American welfare state was devised you
know with the best intentions a lot of
times but also with a perfect model in
one's head that ended up not translating
so well from the classroom to to reality
yeah but you're asking me you know what
whether it's driven by profit or
something else you know I don't think
it's always driven by profit I think
that that the love of a system and I
grant you that you no no no no belief
system is immune from from the draw of
the perfect system I mean we strive for
order in the universe and when there is
a system that promises it you know and
especially something that's so
all-encompassing that it claims to be
able to explain everything and to solve
every problem all it was like
trickle-down economics its enormous ly
seductive and if you happen to be a
brilliant mathematician and you can make
it all work out
then then then all the more so but I
think it's very hard to so I'm not
arguing that Milton Friedman was out to
make money from these ideas I think you
know he talks you know about about he
talks talk personally about falling in
love with with math and wanting to
spread that love I mean he says that he
said that that all of this came out of
this the this love of math and that he
was passing that on to his students and
you know arnold harberger who is one of
his closest colleagues and was the key
figure in training of the Chicago boys
you know he he described the followers
of Friedrich von Hayek the the Austrian
school at the University of Chicago as
you know falling in love with the most
beautiful picture in the world and
loving it so much that anything that
affected that beautiful picture was you
know was was wasn't just bad it was evil
it was evil because it marred the beauty
so I think that there's that okay um but
I but I don't think it's possible to
talk about this has just any ideology
because these are not just elegant ideas
they're hugely profitable ideas I mean
the the connection between these ideas
and the fact that the employees of
Goldman
I've got sixty point five billion
dollars in bonuses you know that you can
draw a pretty straight line I mean
deregulation immediately no not all
ideologies are profitable essentially
but-but-but the Communist the Communist
revolution there was a cadre that came
to power that had more power than
everybody else in the society or use a
uniquely profitable ideology and so it
was supported lavishly by Wall Street I
mean the ties between the University of
Chicago and Wall Street and Milton
Friedman's long friendship with Walter
Wriston you know been well documented
and his it is the statement that I start
the book with that the change that
happens will depend on the ideas that
are lying around that is the mission
statement of the right-wing think tank
infrastructure in Washington and around
the world these are institutions that
are funded with private money from the
wealthiest families in this country this
is not an organic intellectual movement
yeah in the same way that populism or
socialism are bubble up from below this
is this is an intellectual movement and
has been coddled and generously funded
from on high which is not to say that
each person is out to make it rich
although you know I do think I show some
pretty persuasive examples of the ties
between the intellect intellectuals and
the military complex like Richard Perle
and his you know venture capital firm
and so on but you have a lot of very
coddled intellectuals know and set up in
think tanks where they think profitable
ideas and I do refer to them as people
paid to think by the makers of tanks
because I think that more and more you
have homeland security companies and
weapons companies actively funding the
think tank infrastructure which is quite
disturbing because they're also in a
financial gray area where if you're the
prayer if they were lobbyists they would
have to disclose where their money was
coming from but as think-tank denizens
they we know almost nothing about where
their money is coming from and you know
we found out that the American
Enterprise Institute was getting money
from big oil companies to Commission
behaviors debunking global warming well
what if they're also getting money from
weapons companies to create the context
of this never-ending war we need to ask
this question but just to to go back it
seems to me that I you know I can't
argue with you about the economics of
the think tank world but I would argue
that you look at the people who get
hired by think tanks they have they have
ideologies that they've usually bought
into before going into the think tank so
I mean you're there making the think
tanks may play this role but it doesn't
necessarily imply the intellectual
dishonesty of the people who occupy them
no but but this is why I think will
never really be able to unpack it right
it just it just go to some of these
specific examples because one of the
things that when you talk about shock
therapy and this type of disaster
capitalism a lot of what you don't you
know dwell on a whole lot in this book
is what what comes before the shock so
before sacks arrives in Russia there's
communism before Hurricane Katrina
there's you know the city was pretty
dysfunctional to begin with before Iraq
there was Saddam Hussein so you're
dealing with you can you can you the
impulse to shock isn't something that's
purely dreamed up in order to produce
produce to produce profit and you know
I'm not denying that there's no profit
motive there but there are some of these
people are kind of reform minded people
who have an ideology that they sincerely
think works best for the world and
there's no arguing with the fact that a
lot of these places you know yeah
absolutely but you know before sacks
arrives in Russia there wasn't communism
there was Gorbachev and there was
perestroika and glasnost and there was
the beginning of a gradual transition
and an opening up and the beginning of a
and the birth of the new democracy of
fragile new democracy in that context
and that to me is what you know that is
- that to me is the tragedy of these
moments of shock is that they really do
rob people of the their right to be part
of the reconstruction of their countries
whether its reconstruction from a
repressive regime no the the idea that
Rockies were being promised
liberation after Saddam and then the
vision of liberation was for Paul Bremer
to rewrite their entire economic
architecture and at the end say okay you
can vote now this to me is a tragedy
people were so enthusiastic at the
promise of actually being able to be
part of their democracy music that the
occupation that the Iraq war could have
under different management worked out in
a different sort of way um you know I
can't go into those hypotheticals
because to me it was you know such an
ideological campaign that the idea that
that could have happened from this group
of people it just it was just never in
the card so I I don't see how I could go
there I'm but having been in Iraq in
that first year I certainly saw the
tremendous appetite for real democracy
and it I mean the stories that I tell in
the book of these moments where there
was so much hope in these transition
periods you know after the election of
solidarity in Poland or after the
election of the African National
Congress in South Africa and people
believed that they had people had fought
these tremendous liberation struggles
and they were ready for their power now
and suddenly it was shocked out of their
way by these foreign experts I mean this
to me knows it's a terrible crime really
know maybe Lika what's that you know but
but but it's it's um it's a betrayal of
these liberation struggles so we're in
that we're in the territory of
discussing alternatives to disaster
capitalism and you've laid out one one
alternative which is to let I mean it
one alternative in some of these
situations which is just let let the
situation unfold internally I mean New
Orleans is a good example right because
new you know that this disaster
liberated more than a hundred billion
dollars in reconstruction funds for that
city and the the school system in New
Orleans was a disaster before I mean
nobody would argue against that and
there was you know quite a lot of
community organizing going on in New
Orleans demanding a better public school
system and the tragedy of having the
think tank infrastructure and the
ideologues descend on New Orleans and
turn it into a petri dish for the
charter school system is it is the way
in which that
jobs the residents of that city from
building the school system that they
wanted now maybe they would have decided
they wanted a charter system but they
never got the chance to even express
that in a disaster situation like New
Orleans or you know I don't see what the
alternative is when you have home you be
part of the proper
you do have you do have chaos and you do
have a situation that you know demands
some some measure of stability first
well stability but also expertise and
technology now I mean we may not like
this Jim gets used as an excuse for just
getting rid of democracy and overriding
people's wishes you know I have more
faith in people than that I think there
does need to be some stability before
there can be democratic participation
but this impulse to rammed through in
the window of opportunity very dramatic
reforms I just think it's just
anti-democratic and it isn't true I
think that the language of trauma is
often used to sort of pathologize a
people who have just suffered a disaster
when in fact the best way to recover
from a great trauma is to be involved in
the in the reconstruction I mean when I
was in Iraq people were so enraged that
their expertise their knowledge of their
country was not being drawn upon to to
reconstruct you know I mean just the
just the the spectacle of these huge
foreign companies coming in with their
own experts with their own workers you
know who they brought in from from Nepal
or you know or from India Iraqis watched
this and they saw it as an extension of
the invasion and the insult really to
the national character to say you know
whatever unit this is your I know this
is your country but we know better this
fed the insurgency and you know the
experience of living through a shock you
know taking it out of Iraq the
experience of living through a terrible
disaster is the experience of total
helplessness right it's its parents not
being able to protect their children
when a huge wave comes to their village
and you know it's husbands and wives
being separated and being put on
different buses and taken to different
states and you know in New Orleans and
they turn you know I start the book with
a quote from a resident of the Lower
Ninth Ward and
orléans saying when I rebuild this
school talking about the public school
I'm rebuilding myself when I rebuild the
city I'm rebuilding myself because the
the cure for helplessness is not being
you know treated like a trauma survivor
who you know needs to be kept away and
and you know have things done for them
the cure for helplessness is actually
helping being you know being empowered
to be part of of some kind of a
rebuilding process I think people are
capable of it not only are they capable
but they deserve it and it should be a
right you seem to be saying that there's
there's a possibility for some if you if
you're able to purge this drain of a
free market fundamentalism or gloom
idiotic rats yeah that you know some
sort of liberal democratic capitalism
wouldn't be the worst system in the
world no I mean you know I think that
the book you know is I'm getting flak
from the left for how Keynesian the book
is I mean it really is an argument for a
mixed economy but more than that it's an
argument for democracy I mean what the
tragedy to me of these junctures where
you have these liberation struggles
where people vote for a political party
that's promising deep democracy and then
they end up getting shock therapy
instead and and their vote is made
hollow you know not only is that a
betrayal of democracy but it's dangerous
I look at some of the countries in
Eastern Europe where this has happened
we're seeing a rise in extremism
nationalism fascism racism zone need to
be failures to see that and they come
boundaries in all the countries in
Eastern Europe where shock therapy
wasn't applied like you know Belarus and
in Uzbekistan and some of these other
you have you have other authoritarian
governments and extreme levels of
poverty - well I mean I think this is
but this is entire I mean what the
tragedy of this to me is you know the
post-war consensus was that a terrible
mistake had been made in Germany because
in during the in the Treaty of
Versailles and this was what Keynes
warned against in economic consequences
of the peace that if you punish a people
like this if you deliberately induce a
depression which was you know the
punishing sanctions on why we're Germany
he said revenge will not limp and he
warned the
this that the second that the revenge
that would follow the rage that would
follow would make the first world war
look tame by comparison and he was
ignored and after the Second World War
there was a consensus that it was
dangerous to shock countries but there
wasn't I mean just to be clear you're
not saying that people like Jeffrey
Sachs and Paul Wolfowitz went in with
the same sort of putative impulse that
the Allies had against Germany in the
1920s right they were they were
ultimately intending for these societies
to to prosper their former shock therapy
maven Huber istic but it wasn't it
wasn't malicious I think there was an
amazing failure to learn from that
history that I don't understand because
we actually do know this history and all
all of these figures are well-versed in
it I mean I learned about it in grade
four so I don't know you know that you
know you create a depression and you
look for a scapegoat I mean this is how
the Holocaust was explained to me as a
kid right um so I believe it was known
and I and I don't know why we are we
have failed to learn this lesson of
history I don't think it was malicious
but I also don't think it's excusable
because I think was because it's so
predictable and I you know this is why I
I looked so deeply into the in the book
into the prom